now just a day to go before elections in
the u.s
president donald trump and his
democratic rival joe biden have
been making their final pitches to
voters trump has been holding campaign
rallies in five battleground states
meanwhile biden's campaign is focused on
pennsylvania
trump believes he can pull off another
surprise victory as he did four years
ago
most polls though have been showing
biden ahead in key states
needed to win
well many eyes will be on the biggest
swing state of all
florida it's been seen as a must-win for
donald trump
the past two elections have seen a
wafer-thin margin between the winner and
loser there
president trump is banking on the
support of one of the state's
main voting blocks the latino vote
dw's carolina chimoy has been to find
out
how the republicans under president
trump have tapped into a narrative
that's found appeal among florida's
cuban americans
they want to see donald trump stay in
the white house
and they are determined to deliver
florida for him
it's a must win state for the presidency
even at this scaled-back democrat rally
in orlando
the trump voters are far louder
trump has strong support from a large
part of the latino community here
in florida this despite things which
would seem almost designed to put
latinos off
like the harsh words he has used to
describe immigrants
i'm here to find out why the hispanic
vote leads more republican
here in florida nearly a third of the
latino voters in florida
have cuban roots including bertica
cabrera morris
head of latinos for trump in orlando she
was 15 when her family fled cuba
after losing everything to the
government of ivel castro they just
knocked one day at the door and they
said
it's ours now we had lost everything you
know we had lost our beautiful home
the ranch the chauffeur but we had a
different life
and you adapt that's why voting is so
important to me
because it's a gift that this country
has given me that i didn't have
i don't they took away one of her
biggest fears like many other cuban
americans
is the idea that the system they fled
could be adopted in the united states
no i don't think joe biden is a
socialist
or a communist but i do believe the
people around him are
and they have the same socialist ideas
that i lived through in cuba
and i've seen in venezuela so yes i do
believe that he surrounded
with that and a leader is as good as the
people around them
being pro-trump is slowly becoming
something the president's supporters
keep to themselves
because there can be consequences miker
plummer
is also a devoted trump supporter so i
have a president for you
what's that i have um all right
um supporting our president yeah the
last job the last job i was at
he says you're not a trump fan i said no
why because
i wouldn't let you do the job if you
were a trump fan so i told her i was a
biden fan just to do the job
and that's the only way i could get to
work
it's not just the fear of socialism
driving support for trump
latino voters are catholic and support
the republican position
against abortion and it may seem
counter-intuitive
but many also support trump's heart line
on immigration
even from latin american countries
trump tells the truth i don't want other
hispanics to come into the u.s
even if they are from my country peru if
they don't pay taxes
that is not fair so if more hispanics
come and don't pay taxes they seal
and leave off the money they get from
the government then i'm a racist too
and i also say get out it's not fair
that those that come through the border
illegally paying a coyote ten thousand
dollars
to come here and we don't know who they
are they could be rapists
here in florida support for president
trump and the republicans
is deeply emotional if that support is
reflected at the ballot box
it could decide the election immigration
policy will be a major issue for voters
appearing to get tough on immigration
has been at the heart of donald trump's
presidency
the main agency in charge of deporting
people without legal documents is the
u.s
immigration and customs enforcement
known as ice
and many live in fear of its reach dw
correspondent carolina chimoy sent us
this report
from the state of georgia
nichols is a defender of immigrants
rights she wants them to know that they
don't need to hide where they come from
her organization glare the georgia
latino alliance for human rights
has been working on this for 19 years
until recently
in dialogue with the federal government
but that channel of communication to
talk about
immigration is cut off by the trump
administration she says
obama deported a lot of our people
however
there was room to negotiate immigration
policies
it was a political fight
now on a federal level that is not
possible anymore
this is why they now work on a local
level going from door to door to
motivate people to vote
they hope to elect politicians who will
work with them on immigration reform
and prevent deportations this man from
central america who wants to remain
anonymous
had lived in the u.s for six years with
his family
then one day in 2012 he was stopped by
ice agents
they took him to the irwin county
detention center
there everyone cries even the strongest
men cry
i saw it a big man another one with a
mustache and all crying
because there is no certainty that
you'll ever get out
after three months in detention he was
released with legal help from adelina's
group
who showed he had no criminal background
under the current administration his
release would not have been possible
the american dream doesn't exist anymore
today it's more an american nightmare
especially with this president
he now constantly fears he could be
arrested again
on any given day around 50 000 people
are in migration detention in the united
states
human rights advocates report cruel
conditions
and they say it has even gotten worse
under the trump administration
a system that is unlikely to change
overnight even with a different
administration the change at the top
could at least reopen that door to
dialogue
[Applause]
let's bring in william gluecroft here
from our u.s election team
good to see you so uh florida
very complicated demographically how
important
is it in this election complicated is a
nice way of putting it it's often the
butt of the joe of a joke in america
politically socially culturally i mean
there are social media accounts that
follow all of just the crazy news that
sometimes come out comes out of florida
that said it is an extraordinarily
important election almost
every winning president in recent
history has won florida
and you can't really win the presidency
without winning florida and it's such a
diverse
state 17 of registered voters in florida
are now
latino which is a huge amount of
voters but also we have a huge
retirement population we have
rural white voters you have a large
jewish population
um you have an increasingly young
population
all of these are competing groups and
you know we talk about latino
but that in with itself is a diverse
group we're talking about people coming
from dozens of countries or their
previous generations have come from
dozens of countries with hundreds of
experiences
you know when we talk about for example
in comparison black americans
80 to 90 percent of black americans vote
democrat they are much more reliable
in politically speaking electorally
speaking a much more uniform group of
people
when we're talking about latinos it's
important to say
uh we saw in the report many trump
supporters but the majority are still in
florida going to go
for biden but you do have a breakdown
where there are
more people voting for trump we saw this
in 2016. you had
uh 35 percent of all latinos voting
for donald trump but 54 of cubans within
that group voting for donald trump okay
and when you talk about cuban americans
they are really concentrated in in
florida but let's broaden this out a
little bit talking about the latino
vote in the u.s it is incredibly
important but they don't
vote as a monolithic group absolutely
there's a lot of diversity within
the latino absolutely in the u.s so how
do they lean though politically as
group i mean they lean democrat yeah
we're looking you know two-thirds of
latinos in 2016 regardless of
their specific circumstances voted for
hillary clinton and we're looking at
about that same
for joe biden um and latinos are a
growing population you know four out of
five of them are u.s citizens they have
they have u.s citizenship they have
voting rights this is no longer the
immigrant story that's stereotypical
immigrant
story we always hear these are tried and
true americans who have been here
for generations now for groups such as
cubans and venezuelans
as you heard in the report this word
socialism is a code word for them you
and i might hear socialism think
something very different
but for them that's a scary word because
they're coming from countries where
socialism
means political prisons and it means uh
taking land away from
from landowners and these kinds of
things and these are many of the people
who lost
out to those socialist revolutions in
their countries and came to america to
find a different
way of life to find what they would
perceive as freedom
and that leans them more conservative
but again we need to be careful say it's
still a minority group but the question
is
these as we said at the top these razor
thin margins it might be enough
to tip an election one way or another
the fact is we just don't know
william thank you so much uh that was
william blue crop from
our u.s election team